do you not have a beard so that kids and
things don't think you're obi-wan Kenobi
yeah just to hide from my obi-wan Kenobi
Ness well is that because no I have
chased after kids who don't believe that
I am obi-wan Kenobi I once I once I saw
in somebody's eyes once I was driving my
kids to school and I was at a stop sign
and some this is the thing about la you
get like 16 or 15 and a half year old
driving cars blue pastures at a stop
sign and I thought that was very
dangerous because it was and I pulled up
I've raced after him and my daughter
with Nick don't dad don't I will and I
pulled up beside them and I started
raging and you idiot you can idiot like
I said my daughters were going like that
I saw in his eyes I saw the that's
[__] obi-wan Kenobi I thought you
were doing well until you said I've
pulled up alongside that I've got me
window
[Music]